[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je peux vous mêmes peurs c'est mon job
vous aviez pris rendez vous hector saxe
contrôleurs des normes
j'arrive toujours à l'improviste c'est
mon job monsieur salle
vous en avez trouvé ce qu'on va faire de
vous
ligne ou si ça qu'ils se transforment en
chauve souris c'est un vampire un zombie
regarde et dégage de là où je te plombe
avec un poireau
[Musique]
mouret
tu es déjà mort atteint 12 rallyes
oui ce premier tour si je mange bien en
faire
[Musique]
quoi
e
debout
vous
je te les dites est déjà morte
[Musique]
ah c'est la dernière fois que je vais
récupérer un monstre ya pas marqué
fourrière ici et ma voiture qui doit
être en train de cramer à leurs 30 ans
qu'elle monte d'un papa tu en acheter
une neuve plus c'est pas le moment
j'arrête de m'occuper de ce type tu es
en stage tu fais ce compte qui fait un
boulot pour moi ça tu préfère vendre des
ballons d'une autre monstre de série
dette n'ont pas leur place dans parquet
leur place à douze avaient ou allaient
c'est tout en bas en enfer series
j'en ai plein de cette fille à papa
sérieuse en même le dans sa cellule à
kiev
et c'est quoi ces kandel boys de
supermarchés a laissé mon sac
[Musique]
oui mais tout à fait comme il se doit
d'être maintenant tu t'es servi de moi
j'aurais dû monter
oui je vous la passe c'est ton papa au
pardon alors ma fille mon stage se passe
bien
qu'est ce que tu veux
je veux que tu emmènes les zombies en
enfer en enfer jamais tous les monstres
leur plateau-repas ritchen nous venons
de signer un pacte avec les humains est
désormais se parquer de l'heure ils
veulent des vampires qui transpire des
paillettes pour émouvoir les gamines
c'est leur choix c'est la loi du marché
si les zombies ne s'en vont pas le parc
ferme et bien sûr terme et les vampires
descendront avec leur s oblige pas à le
faire moi même
tu enfermé jeu des pronos
dubé soir
[Musique]
à
je t'ai repris et pouvoir ainsi que les
espoirs que j'avais placé en toi et
puisque tu aimes tant les on lit tu
finiras ton stage en prenant leur place
aux barbes à papa
[Musique]